have you ever been audited by the IRS
I've had four audits I won them all
particularly in California California is
worse than the federal IRS cuz they're
broke four audits after I left the state
of California they tried to say that I
left incorrectly oh wow they lost that
one so the second one was you had some
real estate in California you did a 1031
into another deal and when you gave your
partner who had no equity a bonus he
moved to a different LLC and when you
did it violated the 1031 I said I appeal
it they said we knew you would we've
already denied your appeal I said look
you haven't even got my appeal we're
denying it before you appeal it total
communism how many years after you left
almost seven 7 years after you left they
came after isn't that the the maximum
that they have is it seven years yeah
they have whatever term they want cuz
they'll tell you look if you don't pay
the 750 we'll freeze your accounts I'm
like freeze my accounts my accounts are
in Miami they said we can freeze your
accounts anywhere in the world wow